Es la primera vez que un ministro de
ejercicios enviados frente a esta corte
de justicia de la república que es la
encargada de enjuiciar a los ministros
en sus decisiones y alguien conocido
como absoluto del rey de la absolución
de su época como abogado es acusado por
un sindicato de jueces y una
organización anticorrupción Ellos dicen
que hay conflicto de intereses en varias
de sus decisiones como ministro y que
básicamente sería un ajuste de cuentas
de su época como abogado la primera
investigación pedida por tipo criticada
por sus acusadores es una administrativa
en contra de tres jueces que en su época
de abogado habrían analizado sus
facturas telefónicas como parte del caso
conocido como Paul bismut en que el ex
presidente Nicolás sarkozy es acusado de
corrupción justamente lo que se buscaba
era al informante que desde el poder
judicial entregaba información al ex
mandatario la otra investigación
solicitada por el ministro que es
criticada por sus acusadores es
administrativa en contra de otro juez
que se encuentra actualmente Mónaco que
habría inculpado a uno de sus clientes
cuando él era abogado el grupo magueti
niega las acusaciones dice que no hay
conflictos de intereses sino que siempre
ha seguido Los consejos de su
administración ha pedido además a sus
abogados que soliciten la intervención
de la Corte Suprema en este caso